I ask about the one-sided yeah yeah okay
yeah sure okay so you you guys do a
little bit unconventional of a
relationship right yeah can you tell me
about it so yeah so in the beginning you
know I'll admit it gonna make me sound
like a but in the beginning like I was
like seeing girls behind her back and
then eventually we came to terms with
the fact that you know we're just like
what made it work the best was that I'm
just fully upfront and honest about all
of it and then we have like certain
rules so like I don't have girls
sleepover I don't go out on dates with
girls
um I shower if I see a girl you know I
shower afterwards and stuff like that